[Music]
Just listen.
You said you were Batman. I've got your
back. You know that. How can you even
say that?
Exactly.
Look at you. Look at what you did. You
did it right from jump. What's having
your back means letting you do the
dumbest? Yeah. No matter what.
Who the you calling up? Calm down, girl.
It's me.
Your family. I've always got your back.
Even when you don't have your own. I
just I I don't want you to do something
that you regret. I don't want you to
I get it, bro. I'm sorry. All right.
I'm just pissed.
I know.
I trusted the guy.
I know. I know. Look, it's over. I had
the beef squashed.
So,
are we good?
Wait.
Well, that good still
[Music]
a
I knew it was you. You little come in my
yard yet. Right in front of my daughter.
You t haven't you had enough, man?
Thought we were boys. Is this how you
[__] do me?
Yeah.
Don't act dumb, bro.
I know what you did.
I would say honor to it like a man, but
clearly that's asking for too much from
a like you.
You thought you could get away with
screwing me over?
The are you talking about?
Thought I wouldn't know. Nah,
I wasn't going to let that slide.
That could never be me. That's why I had
to mess you up
right in front of your door.
I swear you. Let's just leave this.
Hey guys, look. Let's just leave this.
All right, look. You messed up. He
messed you up. All right, let's just
leave this now and part ways before this
gets any worse.
Nah,
I don't like that threat. Yo,
so come on, do something. Come on then.
Now you haven't got youring boys to hide
behind like the you are.
I don't need them.
It's just I beg you, man.
You should listen to him, Max.
You don't want to end up like your dad.
What?
No, you're good.
I want you back. Remember?
I know you do.
I got yours.
Handle this rat
by myself.
Axe. Axe.
Axe.
Max, stay with me, bro. Stay with me,
Max. Stay with me. It's all right.
[Music]
We appreciate you taking the time to
come down to uh speak with us.
Mr. D.
Well, it's not like you guys gave me
much of a choice. What you guys want
from me? Honestly, we want to help you.
So, I guess this is the good cop and
Smiley Joe over there is the bad cop.
Don't you guys think it's time to get a
new routine?
Do you think this is a joke or
something, Omar? We're not your local PC
plaude coming for a quick chat. We're
MI5, so keep joking around. See how that
goes.
MI5? You guys are funny.
Listen, sister.
I'm not your sister.
Mr. I'll put it plainly to you. I don't
want either of us to waste our precious
time.
You're here for a reason. As are we.
We're here to protect this country and
the people that live here from any
potential terrorist threats.
Now, at this moment in time, we have
reason to believe that you are one of
those threats.
We want to give you the courtesy of
explaining your side. Help you out.
Well, you guys think I'm a terrorist.
No, no, not exactly. We just have reason
to believe through compelling evidence
that you have connections, shall we say,
to terrorist organizations.
We also have strong evidence that proves
your guilt in attempting to indoctrinate
minors, imposing fundamentalist beliefs
on them in an attempt to recruit them.
This is an absolute joke.
We just want to work with you to find
out what's really going on. We're not
the bad guys. Help us help you.
I thought I was a terrorist. Why would
the MI5 want to help a terrorist? If
you've got so much evidence, why am I
still here?
It's to give you an opportunity to
explain yourself. Maybe even
cut yourself a real good deal.
What do you even mean? I don't even know
what the hell you want.
Axel Davis.
What?
Or as you used to call him, Axe. Based
on our findings when running a
background check on you, you and Axe
were best bugs. Isn't that right?
I don't know what he's got to do with
this. I don't even know what you're
talking about.
You see, on paper, as you are right now,
to most, you'd seem like an ordinary
guy. You teach young boys in a six form
literature as well. So, you're obviously
well read, educated, nothing out of the
ordinary, right?
But you and I both know that's not who
you really are, Omar. You've got a dark
past.
secrets that I'm sure would make your
new persona crumble to the ground if
they were let out.
Don't we all? Right.
Not like yours. Not all of us are best
friends with the main enforcer of a
notorious East London gang after all.
Being Ax's best friend, you must have
found yourself in a lot of shady
business. Business where you'd hurt a
lot of people.
That was 14 years ago. And yeah, Axe
done some bad things, but he wasn't a
bad guy. I still don't know what this
has got to do with anything.
Huh? Stop it.
Say no mind.
Hey, where you man been?
I'm waiting for time. I thought we
supposed to link up at 10.
Yeah. Yeah. Sorry about that, bro. We
just fought
there's more steel.
Bro, did you guys nick this?
Yes, bro.
From that fresh guy down the road, Len.
I swear I wish you could have seen this
brother running after us. It was so Jo
man was screaming at us and everything.
Hey, you bloody thieves. Come back. Come
back.
You to jokes, man.
Yo,
excellent.
Want sandwich?
I said don't come back here until I've
seen the money.
I don't want to see your face again.
until he paid the money.
Get out of here.
Yo,
that don't pay up by tonight.
You let me know. Yeah.
All right.
Is that your mom?
Huh?
Don't act down, bro. Did you just ignore
your mom's call?
Yeah, man. She's been on my case lately,
bro. I can't be asked for that [__] in
the morning, man.
She's your mom. Of course, she's on your
case. She cares about you.
I wish I could say the same for mama.
Yeah, all mine.
It ain't like that, man. Look, I'll
holler at her later. I can't be dealing
with that now.
You be good to her, bro. She don't
deserve none of that behavior. She's
good to you.
Bare mama will come knock you out. Is
it? Is it
Mr. Ayad,
so you've been teaching for 4 years now,
correct?
That way.
So you've had
So you've had the pleasure of
teaching many young men, shaping their
minds.
Sort of.
Well, how would you describe your job,
Mr. Ed?
You've never been to school, agent?
Well, we've never been to a school where
our English literature teacher
recommends multiple Islamic lectures to
watch, including the works of known
extremists.
Yeah, sometimes I do like to speak about
Islam with other Muslim students, but
it's not like I'm telling him to watch
Osama bin Laden's vlogs.
Do you remember a particular student by
the name of Ununice Azimi?
Yeah, I think I told him about two years
ago. Well,
it seems you had a a big influence on
him. Some reports even suggest that you
were one of his role models. Would you
agree with that observation?
Look, I'm not anyone's role model. I
just care about these guys. I see them
struggling and I'll try and help them.
Help them out. How? What do your
religious beliefs have to do with
teaching Shakespeare to a bunch of
teenagers?
Quite a lot, actually. It's because of
the religion I am who I am today. It
saved me. If it wasn't for the religion,
I don't think I would have made it past
my 30s. If I see them going down a
certain track in life, I cannot just sit
back and do nothing. I want to try and
help them make the right choices. It's
interesting you said it like that.
Seeing someone
go down a certain track,
I can relate to that. Let's try it. I've
seen so many people just like you go
down a certain track and just like you
want to help your students
who want to help you.
Looks like the old days aren't so long
gone after all, huh? What sort of
teacher would post such a violent image
on their personal social media account?
Mr. I implore you to please take this
very seriously.
Possession of an illegal weapon is a
serious
This is me. Yeah. Doing target shooting
in Canada. We all do it.
Well, see, now that you've spoken to us,
we have a better understanding of the
situation. Mr. Ayad, at the end of the
day, we want what's best for the people
of this country.
And whether you believe it or not, that
does include you.
[Music]
Y
how that teacher doing
what's his name bro?
The one teacher who's always bugging
man. Mr.
your neighbor,
Mr. Rock.
Mr. Stone. Yeah,
he's still a clown, man. He's always on
my case. You traumatized him, bro.
Hold up.
Why is Stone always on your case?
You're a brainiac.
No, man. Not even.
What are you talking about?
Allow school, allow books, allow exams,
allow all of that.
All that Shakespeare crap, it's all
bull.
And I'm never going to get a job that's
going to feed me like moving stash with
you. Who told you I want you moving
stash with me?
Ain't none of us got a brain like yours,
bro.
We actually got all odds against us.
Ain't just a matter of lacking education
for us, bro.
I walk into an interview, all they're
going to see is a black hood rat.
Yeah. When I walk in, all they're going
to see is Omar Ayad. And they ain't
going to hire me.
That might be true
if it weren't through your intelligence,
bro.
And I ain't seeing it right now, bro.
Talking nonsense to me, bro.
What's your problem?
You've been through life together. We've
done together.
I'm in the game with you.
Nah.
Nah. I don't want you with me, Omar.
me off now, bro. What do you mean, bro?
You don't want me with you.
I thought it was your boy. Exactly.
You're more than my boy, Omar.
You're my brother.
I swear down. If you don't realize what
you're actually capable of,
make a good life for yourself.
If you want to be a bum like me and the
rest of my crew, I'll mess you up, bro.
Look,
I ain't even about you no more.
You're a genius.
Now I've seen you at school.
Even when you're chilling with me and
the boys, the way you talk ain't like
us. You ain't telling me you want to
throw all that away just to bang out
road like your boys.
Not for me.
for your mom, not
not for yourself.
Think about all our boys who are gone.
Our boys
had hopes
and dreams.
Love crippled them until they're forced
into the game.
Then there's you
who has a choice that most of us don't
have.
You want to act a fool.
I don't just want better for you.
I know you can do better.
Ain't just some dream or false hope for
you. It's real.
And I want to see it for myself.
And if you flop me,
I'll kill you myself.
Yeah.
Promise me.
Promise me you won't waste your life.
Promise.
You're actually so jarring sometimes.
Mr. Riyad, I appreciate that this can be
strenuous and tiring,
but the sooner we get to the conclusion
of this interrogation, the sooner we can
all
I am actually. All right.
Hey,
look. It's just us two now, right? So
what? Now that she's left the room, hope
you'll be more willing to cooperate.
Cooperate.
I've been cooperating all day.
Look, I I feel like we've made a bit of
a misstep.
I don't think you're a national threat.
I In fact, I think this is all just one
big misunderstanding.
Congratulations. I think that's the
first smart thing you've said all day.
I like you, Mr. Ryder. You're a good
guy. I can tell.
We need people like you to help fight
the real fight out there.
Get out of my way. Stop right now. What
the hell is going on here? I tried to
tell her to wait, but she
she has a name
and she has every right to be here
during your legally subversive
interrogation.
Sorry, who are you?
Amir Ayad, Omar Ayad's legal adviser.
Wait, I as in
Look, my personal relationship to the
client is irrelevant here. What is
relevant is the law and my client's
rights. First of all, contrary to how
you have made it appear to Omar, he's
not in police custody and is therefore
free to leave without answering any of
your questions. A right that I'm sure
you failed to make clear and essentially
dismissed during your extraction of him
from the workplace.
And so, we assure you
this so-called interrogation is nothing
more than an intimidation tactic used to
extract as much information from naive
victims of your facade. Show's over. I
believe I made myself clear enough.
Yina.
Well, guys, it's been fun.
What
the hell just happened?
These people, man, I I swear to God,
they have absolutely no shame. I can't
tell you the amount of times they've
dragged some moss Muslim from his work
or from his home, made him feel like
he's some criminal, and then tried to
pry into his life like the bloody
leeches that they are.
I don't know what you're laughing about,
bro. They're in your life now. This
isn't the last you're going to hear from
them. Believe me, it's okay.
How can you even say that? All right.
It's one thing seeing innocent Muslims
go through this every day. All right,
that's hard enough. But for it to happen
to my own brother, I swear to God, I can
go back in there and ring their scrawny,
conniving necks, especially a binted.
Even if they do come back one more time,
they're not going to be a match for the
formidable I am. H
Yeah.
I know. I'm sorry. I'm just I'm so
angry.
How did you even know I was in there?
Yasmin called me. I swear to God, Omar,
you're just stressed. I'm going to die a
very young age because of you.
You got to admit though, I'll make your
life much more interesting, huh?
Yeah. Well, why can't you make it
interesting by being a millionaire or
something?
Yes, you can scrge off me, my friend.
Huh?
Uh moving on though to another crime
story today and new home office figures
have revealed that 6,000 crime
every day with just 6%
they said they're going to stop these
knives being on the street and again
it's almost like the bully.
Uh guys I know he's handsome but let's
cut the staring. Yeah. Otherwise, I'm
going to have to start charging you for
meet and greets with Mr. Persons of
interest here.
Tough room.
What happened, Omar?
Why did feds bust through your classroom
to drag your lanky self to go have a
chat with the MI5?
Look, man. They just been doing what
they've been doing to Muslims for
decades to either ruin your life or to
try and get you to ruin someone else's
life.
What? Like spy? A snitch?
Well, it's been nice knowing you.
Omar,
I wasn't expecting to see you here
today, especially so early.
Well, you know me. Full of surprises.
Omar,
I think I need to have a word with you.
Hibs,
I don't think it's the best idea to have
you come back to school straight away
after your
predicament with the law.
There wasn't a predicament with the law.
It was just one big misunderstanding.
Even so, I think it best that we have a
cool down period, take a few days off,
and return to work when things have
settled.
That's some BS, man.
All right, leaving.
What are they going to do? Are they
going to fire me for doing my job?
I ain't leaving.
So glad to hear. Look at you. You're a
bad boy, huh?
Are you, man? There's no way Omar's
coming back, bro. Let's work for me to
do.
Don't be like that, D. He's actually
safe.
Yeah. And if he does come back, then
he's getting mad respect from me for
dealing with them pigs.
He's not about that life. I'm telling
you. What do you even know about that
life? What you think on road?
Yo, dangerous. What?
And I told you boys to sit back down.
You better sit back down before I show
you how far away from that life you
really are. Bro,
why don't all you gangsters take a seat?
Omar, you're back.
Of course I am.
No, it's just it's just that we thought
some of them pigs had you bagged or
something.
Bagged? Back for what?
Come on, no more. You're not fooling us.
You're in the game. We can tell. You're
not like the other teachers. You're
drawn up. You're like us. You're cert.
That was my past. And I'm not about that
life anymore. I don't consider it to be
cert. I was mad when the police came and
interrogated me.
Yeah, we were too, man. I mean, I was
shouting free my guy Omar all day. I
don't think you understand. The very
thing that got me out of that life is
why they interrogated me in the first
place.
Sometimes if you don't conform
to the dominant western ideal, to the
dominant ethic of the west, sometimes if
you're a little bit different,
if you have what they would call, you
know, your cultural baggage that you
bring with you, that you're going to
face trouble.
Sometimes you can just be stopped by the
police because of the color of your
skin.
Sometimes
you're going to be tracked by the
intelligence services because you built
a clock for your school project and they
think it's some kind of a bomb or
something like that.
And that's not a life that we choose.
That is a life that we are forced to
live by.
Gosh, I tell you, feels like ages since
I've seen your uncle Georgie. God, he's
been so busy lately. What of his new job
and that? What job?
His job with the MLBA. Aaron, you really
need to pay attention when I speak to
you.
Oh, I remember. ML
whatever.
What's your problem?
Nothing.
You don't want to see my brother?
Obviously, I want to see Uncle George.
Mom,
then what is it?
Nothing.
That must be him.
George.
Come on.
Hello.
Hi, Uncle George.
So, what's been happening, Jack?
Anything new?
Well, Eric's in her last year, GCSE.
Go on, girl. Going to make us all proud.
You are, aren't you? Great head on them
shoulders. You got
How's it been in the block?
God, I hope they move you somewhere a
bit nicer. So,
ain't that bad, George? We got some
lovely neighbors.
Well, except
except what?
Got this neighbor next door. He's always
making noise and chanting his prayer in
there.
You ain't got one of them living next
door to you, have you?
One of them.
You know, bait Muslims.
What's wrong with Muslims?
A lot of my mem for Muslims.
It ain't the people themselves.
I'm sure if it weren't for that cult
religion, they'd all be decent,
hardworking people. You just can't see
past the fact that they affiliate with
that religion.
What do you know about their religion?
Harriet. George has devoted years of his
life learning about Islam. Think he
knows what he's talking about. Ain't
just me who thinks it, babe. My YouTube
channel's got 50,000 followers and they
all think that Islam is a threat to this
country.
50,000?
Wow, that's fantastic.
Yeah. Look, I went to a freedom of
speech march right down in central and
halfway through the rally, I stood up
and done a speech for the uh MLBA.
I've just got
nearly a million views already
and I can't tell you how grateful I am
to the thousands of you that turned up
in support of us and in defiance of this
backwards ideology that's dead set on
ruining this great country of ours.
That's something to say.
Not really.
Hey, come on then. You're all right.
I just think you've got it all wrong.
And saying you ain't a racist don't mean
you ain't a racist.
You can't just say that and think it
allows the government and show it.
Eric,
I just want to protect everything that I
love. Yeah. I want us to live in a
Britain where we all tolerate each
other, where they can integrate with us
and accept our beloved British values. I
don't hate Muslims, babe.
If anything, they hate me and you and
your mom and everyone else.
I'm just going to nip to it over here.
You remember where it is?
Yeah.
That was incredibly rude, Harriet. You
don't use that language in my ass. You
here?
Oh, but blatant fascism is welcome.
Don't you dare call my family fascists.
You watch your math.
What the hell is this doing in your
room?
Don't go quiet on me now, Harry. What
are you doing with a copy of the Quran?
I was I was I was just having a look
through it.
What is it to look at? This book don't
belong in here. You keep it outside.
Okay.
Who gave it to you, Harry?
My
mom. Listen, George, but ain't like
that. All right. Our neighbor thought
it' be funny or something.
Your neighbor? What? That neighbor?
Right.
No, Uncle George.
Uncle George, just leave.
Shut your mouth now. You've caused
enough trouble.
What
[Music]
ain't
go.
[Music]
Go, go, go.
Go go go
[Music]
go go.